in my previous video introduced with all
credible leaks regarding the final
season of Game of Thrones most
importantly introduced with for alleged
leaks through pages that the today's
news seemed to be prone to the Browning
Times reports that HBO series will shoot
part of its final season in their city
which doesn't come as a huge surprise
knowing that the brony has been the main
filming location for King's Landing ever
since the second season however in their
report especially highlight that this
filming will involve much of the main
cast which means that much of main
characters shall be at King's Landing at
some point of season 8 this matches
perfectly with alleged league script in
which it states that majority of main
characters are present at King's Landing
later in season the to page is said to
be from episode 5 which is the
penultimate episode of the season and
traditionally the most action-packed
says Cersei Lannister and her brother
Jaime having a huge argument in the
throne room from the sound of things
winter has arrived in King's Landing
with a knight king and the White Walkers
at the gates of the capital preparing
for the final attack
Cersei seems to have Jon Snow locked up
in her dungeon so her brother pleads
with her to listen to reason and focus
on defeating the army of the Dead The
Hound and Brienne are also there riding
through the streets of King's Landing
towards the red keep this report
basically confirms that most of
characters will eventually come south
and therefore it perfectly matches fit
League scripts edition this report
particularly highlights that Kit
Harington an actor that plays Jon Snow
is rumoured to be among the main cast
that will film on this location we
should place Jon Snow back in the
capital at some point of the final
season thus also matches perfectly with
leaked scripts as there's written that
Cersei has Jon locked up in her dungeons
as most of you probably know once crew
page involves Jaime trying to come in
Cersei that her true enemies the night
king rather than Jon Snow and therefore
she should release him from the dungeons
he says Daenerys is not your enemy Jon
Snow is not your enemy the only enemies
you have to worry about her outside the
city gates right now Cersei takes her
seat at the throne saying nothing
Jaime inches closer to his sister his
face is contorted in a look of desperate
pleading this has to work jim says
Cersei you are your intelligent woman
you may be jealous you may be cruel but
you know how to place your bets
keeping the only man who can defeat
White Walkers in Chains is not a smart
bet Cersei responds with you would help
me release the usurper tell me after
that Norton fool and his white hair
defeated in night King what do you think
will happen to me in conclusion this
filming you seem to be confirming
originality of four leaks through pages
that were up until now considered
questionable I highly suggested to check
out my previous video if you would like
to know all leagues and spoilers
regarding the final season of which
have already been confirmed